obviously with x passing man um
i mean share your thoughts like like
where were you at like you know
obviously you and x had a very close
brother brotherhood and you know i mean
that poster has been there since before
he passed
that's one of my all-time favorites you
know
um and i was [ __ ] that [ __ ] had me
[ __ ] up man
driving through new york city having hot
97 on and they're playing his [ __ ] and
i'm like damn man like
but but where where were you when you
found out about it man
i was in my room his family actually
called me you
know you know like he's actually blood
family when he called me and um
it was like dragon i mean you know we
about to take him off of the
uh life support and stuff like that so i
kind of knew he passed away before a lot
of
people knew you know like before the
media uh
knew you know i mean so i was already
hurting down you know
yeah it's rough man because it felt like
uh
we saw that versus with snoop this felt
like he was in such a good place
i love to see him i love to see him with
a belly because i was like oh he's
eating good you know what i mean like
like the greatest part about that too
was that
dmx is was always a snoop doggy dog fan
like when i was watching the verses and
stuff like that that's all i was
thinking about i'm saying because i know
the type of fan he is for snoop you know
what i'm saying
like he really respected like snoop dogg
he respect that though right there all
right go [ __ ] that's one person that you
always was a fan of
so that's why when you watch some of the
verses like some of the records that he
put on did you see x get up like oh hold
on this was my
like it really was [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah that was real
i was actually like oh snap this is my
joint right i'm